You're still here.
All right, don't tell Catherine, but
I made a bonus lesson for you guys.
So this lesson is optional, but for
those of you who are eager
to learn more, stick around.
So we'll show you how to add some
new features to your tool belt.
So in this lesson, you'll learn about an
Android component called a view pager,
which will allow users
to easily swipe left and
right between the vocabulary words list.
And this means one less click
between the user and their content.
Now similar to the ListView, the view
pager's populated using an adapter.
So you'll get another opportunity to
see how adopters are using Android.
Now let's started.
>> Jessica,
what are you still doing here?
Hello, Jessica, I see you here,
what are you saying to the student?
Okay, I have better things to do,
I'm going to go home.